good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast today
is january 26th i've been dreaming of
this
all year long my book my book my book
my book is finally out
on the spot that's beautiful thank you
so much thank you it's book day i feel
like it's middle school it's the book
fair
oh my god i hope my mom gave me some
money for the scholastic book fair
this book needs to be included in all
scholastic book fairs that's so funny
that you say that because
literally yesterday some i was watching
something and there was a book fair i'm
like i wonder if my book will
ever make it depends on the fair to a
scholastic book
i don't know about scholastic but maybe
a book fair
somewhere right a fair books a fair
books today's such an exciting day
because the book
is here you guys everyone has started
reading it is already crying is already
laughing
is already understanding did you see
snitch's caption yes
it was so profound i mean i'm just being
inundated with like
messages it's like your birthday is so
much better like i never get this much
love on my birthday like
it's so overwhelming i'm trying to like
read everyone's messages and i just
can't believe like first of all how many
people read it already because like
amazon put it on kindle late at night at
midnight it was confirmed someone tagged
me in their story we got confirmation on
my kindle i couldn't get it at midnight
oh when did you get it
like when i woke up at four interesting
yeah
okay someone had tagged me that it came
out on theirs at midnight so audiobook
came out like a little after midnight so
we didn't really get like a full answer
on our major question
yeah we'll be fine but the books are
here people are reading it the books are
here people have finished it which is so
crazy that is crazy i mean it's a
snackable book i did not want to write
something
super long like homer that book was
terrible that he wrote
he wrote a few and i wanted you know the
long one the obviously ad in the odyssey
that was like the fact that he did that
to us and we all had to walk read it in
[ __ ] high school like that was
disrespectful as [ __ ]
yeah that was hard stuff but i would say
that like
this is similar in its jargon
no it's definitely similar in the sense
that like it's you know well respected
by the literary world
yeah the literary world if you guys have
been feeling some like uneasiness under
your feet it's because the literary
world is quaking today
i'm so glad you said that because i was
really worried i woke up and i'm like it
felt like an earthquake almost
like the ground kind of shook beneath me
and it's obviously just the impact the
butterfly effect from the literary world
literally quaking teeth chattering
yeah it's a crazy crazy time so yes it's
such an exciting day
it's so exciting i've had such a long
day already and i have so much more to
do
but the book is out i took my heels off
so i could you know just be comfortable
and also because given the fact that
your beautiful foot is on the cover of
the book we are going to have some
people coming to the show wanting to see
that foot again
yes and she is here to show it to you
not only are we penetrating the literary
community through this book but we are
penetrating the foot fetish community as
well
and i'm really excited for those fellas
to get here get you a book that can do
both
that's us we have a great show for you
guys today um obviously we're gonna be
talking about my book like pretty much
the whole time
but we have the fast five we have the
bachelorette bachelor recap
and then we have a very special surprise
my husband is in studio
he accompanied me along some of my
festivities this morning
and now he's going to be joining us
because we have a little game we want to
play
we have a really fun game that we're
going to play with him and honestly ben
i'm so happy that you're here
but him being here does throw a wrench
in some of my plans yeah i know
where i was just gonna spend this
episode like trying to get claudia and
maverick back together
jackie's just been on one since
yesterday when she really realized after
reading my book she read it again
that i think my true purpose in life was
to end up with
the boy who stole my heart my first kiss
sorry ben i know you're in studio but
maverick
yeah maverick is the one that got away
and i actually feel like starting today
with this book coming out the sequel is
writing itself because
somewhere he's gonna reach out and
maverick's sister sisters
then she's going to tell him about it
he's going to read it he's going to
reach out
and it's going to be like this beautiful
love story that i think you're going to
be chronicling in the sequel and jackie
is literally assigned herself president
of the maveria fan club
maverick and clutch guys we have ships
and we're building them so
my enterprise is booming no you're right
it is kind of weird now that ben's here
like the joke isn't as funny i'm like
looking at him dead in the eye
yeah saying where are you gonna live
satisfying it's not as funny
no it's not we'll have to wait for
tomorrow um so we have a great show i
think we should just dive right in
because we have so much to do
and i could just sit here and talk for
hours about how grateful i am for the
support that my book is getting like you
have no idea what it means to me to be a
first time author
and just the reception is so positive
and people are like as excited as i am
which is crazy
it's like we've been so excited and then
today like seeing all the toasters be so
excited
has made me like has revamped my
excitement i even put out a [ __ ] bow
shirt for the occasion because i did not
know what you were gonna say
but it's scary she put on a [ __ ] bow
yes my that's this is my [ __ ]
bow yes this is my peter herman top um
and i haven't had an excuse to wear a
[ __ ] bow
all year this is it and i'm so glad that
i finally have a reason to like get
dressed in business casual
today's the day today's the day so i
think without further ado
we're gonna deliver the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and it is only you know appropriate that
today's episode which is really a big
day in toast history is brought to you
by bruce
it makes the most sense and i did brush
my teeth this morning before my
day full of press very big day and i
started it with a brush
now what is the brush it is the best
electr ben
you're making a lot of noise with your
bagels and i'm trying to work here
yeah and you could you could hear about
the brush yeah you
need a brush ready do you want to know
what a brush has been
brush is redefining what it means to
have a perfect smile because a healthy
smile is a perfect smile
so bruce is the best electric toothbrush
on the market in my opinion for a
multitude of reasons one
a lot of them can cost like over 200
bruce is very reasonably priced
and it works so well it's also beautiful
like
i find a lot of them to be like bulky
and ugly and you don't want them to sit
on your counter i go for a very kim
kardashian kanye west
minimal clutter vibe but the brush is
sleek it has a magnetic charging station
we both got the one in pink
it's really the best packaging the best
everything aesthetic on point and we've
also like been going to the dentist
recently and she's been so
impressed by our teeth and we're like we
brush we brush
the brush itself has six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience
it also holds a four week battery life
and has a magnetic charging stand
and a compact travel case they offer a
subscription program where you can never
forget to change your brush head again
because bruce will ship you new
replacement heads every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head
it has a sleek design their electric
toothbrush is modern aesthetically
pleasing
and comes in trend driven seasonal
colors and looks great on your bathroom
counter
get 15 off your brush toothbrush kit and
refill
plan when you use promo code toast at
bruce.com
again that's 15 off the brush kit
toast at b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com that's
toast at bruce.com love it okay first
story
first she said good morning america now
she's saying good morning millennials
claudia ashrae stole the show on gma
today
you guys i said good morning america and
tell us about the experience please
because you sort of just like dropped to
everyone that you were going on gma
yesterday and everyone was like wait did
i hear correctly gma that's so exciting
it's no gmm but still very very cool
it's no
gmm but yes i mean i
things move so fast and so much of my
like press has gotten rescheduled so i
didn't want to say anything because then
it would
like if i had like yeah if i got bummed
it's a neil cavuto effect it's the neil
cavuto effect jackie and i got bummed
from the nail cavito show right when we
like bought
new outfits i bought two [ __ ] bow
shirts okay
i was in the middle of getting my
eyebrows dyed my eyelashes died when he
was like neal kabuto
neil cavuto wanted us to talk about
business and like for us
to be recognized for our business to go
on a business news network
so [ __ ] cnn we were so [ __ ]
excited i bought
two [ __ ] motions no i had my whole
outfit ready to go like moschino dollar
signs code it was just gonna be a
sickening moment and then neil and then
we got bumped
cancelled he bumped us for like some
nato emergency
and it was devastating so now i mean
there's always gonna be a nato emergency
always
but there's not always gonna be two
sickening queens wanting to talk about
business with
neil [ __ ] cavuto no there's not
but you had
a better opportunity today yeah and so i
just didn't want to bring it up because
things move so fast in you know the
television industry
but yes i did good uh good morning
millennials good morning america this
morning it was
so crazy i mean i couldn't go into the
studio because
of covid but they have a remote studio
and i didn't want to do it from home
like this was my moment i wanted
my i wanted a premium camera not my
laptop you know 100
but it made it feel much more real like
i was quaking
actually not like the literary world i
was truly
shook like i had a duty like in my belly
you know and then of course i'm like do
i have to poop or am i just nervous
and then when i was done like it was
gone like duty never to be seen again
but it was good i mean it was really
really like i think i was more scared
for that than i was to ever perform in
front of people like it was just a
different
and i took the opportunity so seriously
like i wore my [ __ ] tory birch
heels yeah they're over there they're
over there i mean i'm wearing my
slippers now this is actually
like nobody saw your shoes i know not
even clothes no i know but like the
people in the studio did
i thought i was like an actual business
very authorial
yeah um it was just an amazing
experience it was
very very scary but i'm like i'm so glad
it's over like i've been wait i was
obviously always excited for pub day
which is what we call it in the literary
world
um but i was really more excited for pub
day at 8 30 or 9 o'clock because i just
wanted it to be over as much as i was
so excited and grateful for the
opportunity completing it
of course it felt like a huge pit in my
stomach so now that it's over now i feel
like i can really celebrate
well the reviews are in and you hit it
out of the park
zach weinrepp said best interview he
ever saw wow jackie oh said beautiful
stunning and smart
what did bruno sweet says bruno sweet
said that's my auntie yeah
he was so proud you should have seen him
beaming bruno i mean
theo didn't get to watch it i was going
to bring him but like i don't know i'm
just trying to take this whole thing
seriously like
because it's a serious day i'm a
first-time author and i can't believe
good morning america like
had me yeah no you did such a great job
i feel like you really summed up what
the books about you got people excited
you showed a little bit of your
personality
while taking it seriously i i'd say 10
out of 10 honestly wow thank you so much
i mean
i couldn't see what i looked like except
there was this tiny little monitor where
i looked
so shiny and i was like freaking out and
it was way too late i love this shout
out
i'm pro shy but then i looked at the
actual tv and it must have been my
monitor because it was a little shiny
but i think a little shine is good yeah
i agree
i so agree it was a wonderful experience
now i can say i've done the today show
and gma so i'm good
and you've done steve harvey steve
harvey
and i've done
maybe that anyone want to have a test
hollywood accent oh i filmed actually
access hollywood yesterday
you know mario lopez is one of the new
hosts oh i think i didn't know that he
was so
cute and funny and we had a great
conversation and that airs tomorrow or
tomorrow speaking of steve harvey though
um i think everyone remembers when you
were on the show but you really give
some
back story from when you went on the
show
in the book i do that was like a pivotal
moment in my career people always say
like what was the moment you knew or
like was there something that catapulted
you
and i think that being invited on the
steve harvey show and that just it was a
crazy [ __ ] weekend in chicago
i read about it in the book i think that
was like a huge turning point for me
like one because i was
really good at it like i was like oh my
god i need to be on tv more like i'm so
sickeningly funny and
like i was annoying but i thought i was
great and that's all i needed was
confidence
and so i always point to that moment
because steve really believed in me from
the very beginning he did believe in you
he invited me back again a really sweet
story in the book that everyone's gonna
love
speaking of the book if you're reading
it now we in your week of press uh you
have your biggest opportunity coming up
it's true she'll be on the redheads book
club podcast where i think it's going
the first interview
about the subject matter of the book yes
you know with people who have read the
book and we're all
talking about what's inside yes so far
i've been doing press like trying to
give little
tidbits but i didn't want to spoil
anything right so this is spoiler alert
central
yeah if you guys have questions while
you're reading the book email them to
the redheadsbookclub gmail.com and we
will ask the author herself
wow ask the author and the literary
world will once again
quake did once again did you see that um
on the tv guide good morning america
referred to me as author claudia ashrae
i did
and they put respect on your name there
was also a lot of good guests
on gmail today wendy williams and i want
to talk about it do you see that they're
doing a lifetime movie
what they're always doing a lifetime
with wendy williams oh what's it about
so she's about her
so she is like i guess like a two
project deal i watched gma this morning
and i found out
um she is doing a docu series like about
her life her breaking into the
into the industry and then like a
live-action movie about like her life
and they gave a sneak peek of a clip on
gma of the scene where the woman who's
playing wendy
faints while wearing the statue of
liberty and the girl does a really good
job
oh wow it'll be i find those movies to
be so weird but they
are but i feel like because wendy's
involved it is going to be better than
some of the others so you should really
watch good morning america more often
it's very informative yeah and then when
you're done with that you head over to
good morning millennials yeah gmm
gmm baby big b okay next
story kelly clarkson's talk show could
take ellen degeneres's spot i've been
hearing this
you know this sort of answers some of
the questions that we had a few weeks
ago
ellen may not be dancing so hard amid
rumors over the future of her show stop
that opening line is hysterical
she is struggling to hold on to her fan
base following troubling accusations
over behave over her behavior with just
one year left on her existing deal
the multi-millionaire host will enter
talks about the ellen degeneres show
next month page six has learned
her ratings have slipped eight percent
according to stats and the kelly
clarkson show which airs after ellen in
most indication markets could well take
the ellen show's 3pm spot
if it comes to an end insiders are
amusing i mean this seems like a natural
progression of things ellen is not going
to stay on the air forever
and after like the last year i think
probably the end of her contract which i
think gives us another season
is probably the best time for her to
step down and kelly clarkson is like a
fresh show
everyone's loving it great guests great
content karaoke so i think it would make
sense for
and i actually think ellen probably
likes kelly clarkson i like to think
yeah i mean i'm sure it will sting no
matter who it is
but at least like there's some i just
feel like right now it's just a tough
time to be
in like daytime talk show or just having
a talk show it's always
a tough business even for a celebrity so
you know
talented and iconic like harry connick
jr you know it's really hard to make it
work and i feel like especially now i
feel like you took that cancellation of
harry's show harry connick jr
i feel like you took that really hard i
did because i used to watch it sometimes
i was getting my nails done and i
thought it was so good
i never saw a lick of it but he's a
handsome fella yeah
so if he can't make it like it's no
you're right kelly's doing it and
but even like when you think about the
drew barrymore show yeah what hap like
it i feel like we heard about it so much
for two weeks and i have not heard about
it since that happens a lot
like there's so much hype for a tv show
like all this money put behind it
and then it's just gone a flash in the
pan yeah so i don't know what happened
to drew
i don't think she's still on she might
still be i don't know i mean the reviews
were not good kelly just really
persevered like
through it all i feel like she put a lot
of time and effort into
styling the show's set and and the whole
run of show and i feel like she was
really involved and it's
really good yeah she also just has that
jenna say quad like you can't put your
finger on it yeah it's just that x
factor of relatability plus celebrity
you know
similar to what we have and it's very
very similar
no i agree i think she's made for this
job and i think it'll probably
it will be her i do and i can't think of
who else would be to replace ellen's
time slot
yeah i agree okay next story a little
new romance hannah brown holds hands
with rumored boyfriend adam willard
on romantic la outing
sh is she officially off the market
hannah brown was spotted getting cozy
with model adam
willard days after bachelor nation fans
identified him as her mystery man
the alabama native was photographed
holding hands with him as they walked
through downtown l.a on monday
in photos obtained by the daily mail the
two some were dressed down in sneakers
and each wore face masks
to keep themselves safe so
new mexico he's a model a famous one
i hadn't heard of him um
but i feel like hannah could do better
not in terms of looks just in terms of
like fame
yeah but i feel like it's kind of maybe
she actually likes him you know
no no i'm sure she does which is nice
but like i just love when famous people
date other famous people
yeah but i also just like hope that
she's happy yeah me too i mean she
really fell off the face of the earth
i know she was everywhere for so long
like in our faces just like dancing with
the stars and just doing the most
and having so much success and then
obviously the scandal happened and then
she just like kind of
lived just a quieter life yeah so but
now she's stepping out with a new man
he's handsome yeah not as handsome as
you ben
no or as handsome as maverick stop
ben wasn't even listening he doesn't
even know what we're talking about um
ben what was the last thing we just said
that's what we'll call it the [ __ ] on
bed show um
also a part of me like is always going
to ship her and tyler sees like
ever since the quarantine crew no
i feel like if it was going to happen it
would have
and it didn't so i'm moving on okay
speaking of
we were talking last night have you been
i mean i know you have but
i'm just going to phrase the question
that way anyway have you seen this video
that's going around
of matt tyler and like a couple of their
couple of their friends playing golf
yes i have there's an instagram story
going around i guess it was deleted but
one of the bachelor fan pages picked it
up
um where one of the guys that they're
playing golf with it's not matt and it's
not tyler
makes like a really not cool
joke about victoria and her body and
then they all laugh
it was really like and again victoria is
like does not herself no favors in terms
of like
being so mean on the show but then like
you see a video like that and all of a
sudden she becomes a sympathetic
character you know victoria's the worst
but that still means doesn't mean you
can't say anything like
no no no it made me feel like so
uncomfortable
and she took it and posted like a
sickening photo
like a like a hilarious photo of her in
a bathing suit and just like
wanted to obviously address it but that
she was really [ __ ] up she also posted
a hysterical meme
um yes of like a beauty contest and like
a guy on the couch
your nose is too big when it's like
these girls are stunning and yeah
there's nothing of the sword and
i i felt like that's it sums it up yes i
agree
um yeah i figured we would talk about
that during the bachelor recap but i
just found that whole situation to be
really disappointing
me too um okay next story for the kma
stands i don't know what this means but
kanye has returned to la
after the quote split but like maybe
he's there to sign the papers
you know i mean or maybe he's there to
go to counseling you could sign the
papers
virtually like with docusign and
e-readers like
you could totally do it virtually yeah
kanye has been spotted for the first
time since page six claimed that he is
separating from kim
the 43 year old rapper was spotted
arriving sunday by private jet at
vietnam
airport in la from his ranch in cody
wyoming where he's been holed up
so this could mean anything yeah like
literally anything and i'm just gonna
take it to mean that like the virtual
counseling wasn't
really going well maybe the wi-fi was
bad in cody and so he
came to l.a so they could do it in
person and fix what needs to be fixed
and move on with their happy family no
that's a definite possibility i do think
it's wild how
we've literally not heard a peep from
either one of their camps
on whether or not this is true like
we're still speculating and i just feel
like by now we normally would have heard
something i just think that
the they haven't made a decision yet
they don't know oh you think yeah i
think that they're trying to work
through it and they'll see if they can
or maybe they're just waiting for the
television show like too
maybe i don't know i just think that
they're
they haven't made the decision i really
do and i i think they're trying i think
him showing up is like this is me trying
this is me trying yeah okay well
honestly
that song he was like he loves the jazz
he loves taylor swift
yeah he does i mean i obviously hope
these two can work it out but if not i'm
just looking for some sort of resolution
this like purgatory period are you or
aren't you
i'm fine with this purgatory period
because if it proceeds it gives you hope
yeah and it's like if the end of this is
that they're over like i would rather be
in this
period where i do have hope yeah i feel
that
okay our fifth and final story is little
sports biz news now that we're the
premier sports podcast
a little sports business
budweiser like coke and pepsi will be
passing on super bowl 2021 commercials
what yep the king of beers won't be
raining over the super bowl 2021
commercial space this year have you
heard this ben
no did you want to join us i feel like
you could give something it's a crazy
story
yeah i mean it makes sense once i give
you the details i thought it was just
because like
2021 is nothing of the sort like why
would we spend 55 million dollars
on a 30-second ad but no that's not it
budweiser is the latest corporation to
back out of advertising during this
year's broadcast choosing instead to
join a public awareness campaign for the
covin 19 vaccine
for the first time in 37 years the
company won't air its game stealing
commercials
they said quote like everyone else we
are eager to get people back together
reopen restaurants and bars
and be able to cheers with family and
friends to do this and to bring
consumers back into neighborhood bars
and restaurants
that were hit exceptionally hard by the
pandemic we're stepping in to support
critical awareness of the kobit 19
vaccine
i don't understand it's not it actually
makes no sense
so they're trying to use like this time
and energy and money
to encourage people to get the vaccine
so that people can start going to bars
and restaurants and people can start
ordering budweiser there okay and the
restaurants could be safe but also like
we could just
also open bars and restaurants also okay
the 55 million dollars budweiser would
have spent
why did you donate some of that to like
the local bars and restaurants that
serve your budweiser yeah
donate them to the bar school fund yeah
no they're like inadvertently trying to
help bars and restaurants
through like a psa to get the vaccine
but like your money would actually go a
lot further if you just
gave it directly yeah they are um
going to route some money to the ad
council's efforts to raise public
awareness about the vaccine
as well as a 90-second covet-themed film
called bigger picture narrated by
actress rashida jones i've had enough
of covid films okay the real housewives
of oc
is just one long film we never asked
honestly this year has been the
unofficial covent film festival
and you're all losers um other super
bowl commercial giants such as pepsi
coke and hyundai
will also take a step back from this
year god
hyundai hi youtube she says it on
purpose
no but like i just pronounce it
phonetically
hyundai hyundai hyundai millennials
ben what do you think about this um i
think that it is
just fake news like they're not
running super bowl ads because the last
couple of years
people are saying that they're not
profitable the reason why that's
stupid is because this year i think
it would be profitable everybody's
sitting at home yeah it's gonna be the
highest rated super bowl it's tom brady
patrick mahomes oh
everyone is going to be watching and
it's worth the premium and the super
bowl ads just
you can't run advertising like that like
through an influencer or online like
those like long-term
have you heard of the morning toast yeah
like sure you could do podcast reads
their money would be better spent here
i'll take the 55 mil they they should
run super bowl ads
can we talk to you about something then
of course you know we did a big super
bowl segment yesterday because obviously
there was a lot of football over the
weekend and we figured out that you know
the tom brady's are going against the
jackson homes
and we want to get your take because you
know we are now one year strong of
predicting the outcome of the super bowl
we knew last year
it was not the time for the san
francisco 49ers it wasn't their time
and we were completely right now before
we make our
official prediction we're still weighing
all of our options we would like you to
weigh in
with your opinion about who's whose time
it is
is it it's it's time summer time
school's out scream and shout sorry
continue
it's it's tom brady's time it's always
tom brady's time
tampa bay buccaneers they went on the
road won three
very difficult games and now for the
first time ever i don't know if you guys
know
everyone knows yeah okay you do uh the
super bowl is played in a neutral site
every single year
we know that all right it's at home give
us something they have a home game it is
crazy though
that well i was overhearing zach's
sports show so i have a thought about
that but it is crazy that that's
never happened before that's what's
crazy or not that it's happening but
that it's never happened
she said it's it's like uh playing a
roulette wheel
yeah yeah now one in 32 chance i hear
what you're saying about it being
brady's time
but i do think you're missing out on
pertinent piece of information
and you're the kind of secret weapon
that the kansas city chiefs have
which is jackson mahomes tell us are do
you follow jackson
homes on tick tock for those who don't
know patrick mahomes is like the best
right he's a quarterback he made 500
million dollars biggest contract in nfl
history
and his brother is a tick tocker who
kind of
travels with him to all the games and
like you know does like
cringy tick tock videos on the jet and
in the suites
and it's honestly so cringy and so fun
to watch and i think that he's a secret
weapon that a lot of sports analysts are
underestimating this year
um first and foremost we have to be nice
to jacksonville homes because that is
the most bullied man in america it's
terrible what they do
is the comments are awful the way you
guys talk about him i would never know
yeah no he's just he's iconic like he's
insanely roasted he's
like the most successful cloud chaser
just like living off of his brother and
i'm living for him
i love that they say such mean things
the kids are so mean to him
he is not even close to the secret
weapon he is
the polar opposite he is an
embarrassment
i'm sorry i said it's we we shouldn't be
you just said the kids are being mean
okay
but it's the truth uh two weeks ago
passenger homes got a concussion in the
game
goes do you have a pimple or something
you're staring at my forehead oh my god
you do have a pimple okay can you like
i didn't say anything you said you
brought it up yeah but you're staring
like there's like i have a
third eye look at the camera don't have
a pimple and then i won't stare
um passionate homes gets a concussion
everybody's so worried
mid game jackson holmes tick-tocking
his brother was literally taken off the
field we live for the third
yes jackson so relatable right live for
the thirst the guy is so popular
jacksonville
700 000 it's not even that good yeah the
most viral platform in the world he
should have 10 million
he could be doing better in terms of
growth ben maybe you should manage him
yeah that's what i need yeah um so
we haven't officially decreed no and
also when i was listening to zach's show
they said that yes
having that home court advantage will be
an interesting touch considering it's
never happened before but this year it's
kind of irrelevant
because one they're bringing in a lot of
like healthcare workers into the stadium
not necessarily
bucks fans like right just because of
the way that this
fan seating is gonna work like it
doesn't really play it
it's not gonna be full of bucks fans no
but to me tom brady gets to sleep in his
own bed
he gets to go into his own locker room
he gets to take a [ __ ] in his own
bathroom
go on the field heated toilet
for sure love that rich yeah
i don't know i'm still wearing my
options i'm leaning towards um tom brady
but travis kelsey he does not lose you
know no the
the chiefs are unbelievable like on
paper there i really think it's the old
guard
this is the new yeah i [ __ ] said that
yes no but then you said it and then
tony korenheiser said it
oh you're watching pti there that's why
he was watching and it's really true
like patrick mahomes is the future of
the sport but
tom brady is the past and the present
and so
will is whose time is it wait no it's
like who are we betting on
the pastor or the future there's one guy
that's been to 10 super bowls there's
one guy that's now going to be in his
second
tom brady has been to more super bowls
twice as more super bowls than
anybody ever patrick mahomes has won
every super bowl he's been in
it's true it's good it's a hot take hot
take
um well thank you for that ben and thank
you for the business news segment and we
will let you know when we come down with
our official decree
we're going to do a little bit of that
recap ben actually watch with me so
maybe you'll be able to give some
insight
about that i know we'll just like breeze
through it because it was honestly a
terrible episode
um and that segment very appropriately
because i needed a few of these last
night to get through the bachelorette
is brought to you by usual wines wines
for the modern drinker
each bottle is 6.3 ounces which is a
heavy pour or about a glass and a half
of wine
there's no more pouring wine down the
sink when you don't want to finish the
bottle because of the single serve
format and bottle design
usual is always fresh no more flat
bubbly or stale rose
the wines are low carb and have zero
grams of sugar
usual has a red blend a rose and a
sparkling white called
brut we also have usual spritz a low
alcohol low calorie wine spritzer that's
made of sparkling wine and guava juice
basically like white cloth for grown-ups
where each serving is just 83 calories
check out their website at
www.usualwinds.com
use our discount code toast for eight
dollars off your first order
and try your first glass on us again
that's usual wines.com
our discount code is toast for eight
dollars off your first order
and try your first glass on us love it
we got brute
and bruce today so let's talk about the
bachelorette we
i mean the episode was so long it was so
bad and so bad and and i've said this
and it's
getting really frustrating because and i
feel like i get to this point every
couple seasons with the bachelor
bachelorette where i just really feel
like they're wasting our time like last
night
we didn't get the the final rose
ceremony we're now we're it used to be
the episodes ended at the rose ceremony
but now it's like the end right before
the rose ceremony it's so frustrating
and these women i i know that women like
victoria
and anna are these like necessary evils
like they make the show go round
but i do feel like we've evolved past
the need for them
yeah i agree i my only thought from last
night's episode is like
one to bring in all these new girls is
so annoying there's so many there's
still too many people there
but the way that the ogs as they call
themselves treated these girls as if
they
chose to come in second string like
they've been at nemacolin just as long
as you've been they've been in a room
alone by themselves you think being here
for matt was hard imagine being
sequestered alone knowing you're coming
in
second string like 100 percent are the
like everyone who's there is some of the
most eligible girls in america you're no
better than them that you got to go
first like
to come in second sucks as it is and
then to
be there and have people treating you as
if you chose it this way
right that was that was the thing like
first of all the new you want to be mad
at someone be mad at the producers
yeah don't be mad at these girls the new
girls coming in
made the old girls look so bad like
come off more insecure and jealous and
then downright mean like being
so catty [ __ ] middle school [ __ ]
and
then when the new girls came in i
couldn't deal with everyone yelling at
them like it was their choice
to show up three weeks late like that's
how the show works you're mad don't you
look britney go yell at mike flice
yeah it was just you're directing your
anger in the wrong place and you're just
being mean
they were being so mean it was really
shocking because i really feel like all
of these girls obviously have watched
every season of the bachelor
know how it goes down and and know how
to get themselves to the other side
looking good on paradise a million
followers that's pretty [ __ ] easy
so to be that mean to them was like oh
you just forgot where you are and who
you are and that is just not acceptable
way to act and even though vibrator girl
was like so
on the right side of history you know
like i'm not like a fan of hers per se
she was completely correct i was
surprised she was alone in that too
like she didn't have anything i know not
one other person who could see it that
way who could see the other side and
like i thought the way that she went to
matt
was the perfect way to go about it and
just say coming from you it would mean
so much more i tried it they don't
listen to me
like she was just on a whole other level
from all of these people just
she was a woman and the rest were girls
100 i was worried that matt was like
not gonna have the right reaction
because he's kind of stinking well so no
the thing is
he's sinking we don't even know what his
reaction is because it doesn't happen
till next week it sounded like he took
what she said seriously but i want him
to ask like who said what and
like if he doesn't take action next week
and send anna home like
i'm dead serious i'm stopping watching
the show because i was getting so
furious watching this whole thing with
britney anna
and the escort of it all yeah so okay so
much of it bothered me
first of all anna just bothers me like
she thinks she's so everything of the
sword and i'm here to break it to her
that she's not
second of all i i it's one thing to like
spread rumors
with baseless accusations like you have
literally no proof
but it's another to do it on television
where that follows you and that's why
katie was getting so upset and i agreed
with her like
and by the way if you want to be an
escort that is your business like your
body do what you want with your life but
like
people exist outside of this show they
have families they have jobs they have
things
and like just to put it out there just
because you felt like being a [ __ ]
bothered me so much and literally as i
was watching the episode i'm scrolling
twitter
and there's this new york post article
and it's like who is brittany galvin the
girl accused of being an escort it's
like that's just what her name is now
you google her because anna felt like it
you know what i mean
yeah no i'm sure she got messages of
people saying that she's an escort but
similar to what was that guy's name from
last season who was like the worst
yosef oh yeah and how there was like all
someone got messages about him
and this girl and it's like i don't care
about dms you got before the show like
unless you're gonna show me the dm's and
go to the source and ask
for their proof i do not care what
anybody sent you before the show and
like
but then joseph proved himself to be an
[ __ ] oh for sure and like he was a
queen
he was the worst because of that but
like not because he had this like
because he ghosted a girl before the
show like who i don't give a [ __ ] no but
like the way brittany handled it she
came out looking like the victor
yeah and so i think if she stays around
longer like i think this whole escort
thing like will be squashed but it's
just like
i just want any contestant who's going
on the show to know like i don't care
what someone told you over dm whether
it's true or not
it it means nothing to the show
everyone's coming on the show like
with a clean slate almost i only know
what i see on tv
yeah no i couldn't agree more i'm not
interested and also
i was confused as the timeline when did
you get these messages because you don't
have a phone
no okay so this is what i think happened
i think the cast was announced i think
those girls who were second string
were announced with the ogs and before
they went someone was like watch out for
her and then i'm sure she showed up
night one and i was like oh this girl's
not here
and then she came in and was like hmm it
was confusing yeah
i'm just done with anna like honestly i
know victoria and victoria was being an
animal last night
and she's so wrong she took the crown
off of that girl's head i was like
this is this is so disrespectful it like
did not sit
right with me but like the thing is is
victoria is like
so bold in her meanness like i almost
like
i i expect it from her i i hate it more
when people like anna like claim like
they're you know
matt needs to know like to do it in a
way that's so fake and
and not you're trying to be earnest but
like i know you're just spreading rumors
100 percent
at least that's why i know that she is
and as much as i find her rude and
disrespectful like i kind of respect the
fact that she's so upfront with her
villainous vibes
whereas like anna's like literally
pretending to smile
yeah it really [ __ ] bothers me and i
was really getting upset and if matt
doesn't do anything like i will be so
annoyed with him
yeah well i will say i'm one i'm glad
they brought in um
group number two because it really
showed everyone's true colors from group
number one
everyone who was pretending to be like
so perfect and sweet beforehand like we
see you now
thank you thank you for showing us the
girl who got a one-on-one was a precious
gem of
precious jedi like i think she will go
very far i think that her and matt have
an outstanding connection
and so i think the ultimate group and
matt's like love connections are better
off for it
i completely agree and i also feel like
the fact that he would send some people
home when he just got these new girls
here it's like
you guys had all this time with that
like if they made more of an impression
on him in one night than you've done in
two weeks
that's on you could not agree more
what ben what about you who oh also kit
is everything of the sort
yeah um who are some of your standouts
i've just been listening to your
dialogue and you know
this show really sucks ass yeah like
that's just like what it comes down to
no you're so right
i've never really liked this show no i
know i really the first episode we
watched together
i really got into it i thought it was
good you watch this episode
fighting for love they have them boxing
it is no
[ __ ] it has nothing to do with
fighting for life
a girl gets socked in the face and he's
coddling her and then the episode like
i guess i think this is right before
that happens he's like working out
shirtless in the jungle
like the whole thing the whole thing is
just so stupid
and like it doesn't make any sense and i
i
raised an excellent point and then yeah
when they read the date card fighting
for love and all the girls were like
oh yeah they're always [ __ ] fighting
for love and i just
ben's right like your ability to beat up
vibrator girl has no bearing on your
connection with matt like it's so stupid
and honestly like
it's so good but are you willing to
fight for him no
yeah because i have to go on a date and
be on television i don't want one of my
teeth knocked out yeah that's terrible
so stupid also i'm i don't remember her
name anna looks
just like phil dunphy's wife the actress
julie yeah that's a good call twins
that's a good cause
um but i like julie bowen much more
maybe too yeah it's it's funny the other
thing that i
hate about this franchise is that you
know that victoria and anna are never
getting sent home even though he does
not like them
they'll get sent home they're you know
what i'm saying like they'll last long
you know like the second uh adam was
getting like so much face time
right at the end there's one rose left
she's like i don't want to get sent home
i don't wanna get sent home you're like
of course
like they're gonna keep her like you
know the rose is going to her then it
goes to her the show's just very very
predictable
i really don't like it last thing i
think that bringing in the second batch
of girls actually was worse for the
second batch i know that the first was
like
really really upset like it was it was
clear but
how much does it suck to come for one
day and be sent home oh yeah
half the girls got sent home they got
there that day so you quarantined for a
month
only one one of the new girls she was
wearing like a bikini
like okay whatever in short hair she got
sent home so she quarantined for three
weeks
awful that's all yeah 100 but also the
girl that made out with him that was
like
britney i like her it was pretty bold
yeah what would your first entrance be
you'll say i'm the bachelorette and i'm
standing at this mansion and you have to
make an impression
hmm i really don't know so don't make
fun of brittany she was just being
she's trying something she was just
being creative when's her having fun of
her just now
i don't think i made fun of her he said
it was bold yeah i think you did i said
bold
um so that's our bachelorette recap and
we'll see if i'm still watching next
week yeah and it's wearing at my
patients
me as well okay now it is time for a
very fun segment called
girl did ben read it the book
so we you know we're gonna tell you what
we're gonna tell you
we spoke a lot of [ __ ] about you i know
you don't listen to our show but we
spoke a lot of [ __ ] about you yeah but i
get all the [ __ ] everybody dm's me like
chloe you said this about you today guys
please stop [ __ ] doing that have you
read it yet
yes we were giving you [ __ ] for not
reading it and you read it a week ago
and i i did update everyone but a lot of
people don't believe you so jackie is
going to
quiz you i'm going to quiz you on some
of the um facts and stories from the
book
great and nothing too difficult let's
not spoil too much because a lot of
people haven't read it yet if you have a
general sense
of the book first question what is the
name of claudia's one true love
maverick yes very good ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding
okay what is one thing that tastes as
good
as skinny feels
[Music]
how am i supposed to remember this donut
oh yeah krispy kreme yeah it's a part of
the list yes
what was your favorite photo from the
photo insert
you know like i could say the one of us
at our wedding like
i'm not gonna lie to you i would have
loved like another photo of us that was
like a little bit less filtered maybe if
you had read the book earlier
um you could have had some input yeah
that's very interesting um
i like all the old photos of you guys
they're really cute uh you and your dad
is a cute one
okay those are good um okay what was
this
movie that inspired claudia and jackie
to start a morning show
i've watched it it's with uh what the
[ __ ] is her name
it's is it called the morning show
that's it's like what the name
i've seen the [ __ ] i watched the movie
with you guys in window i'm just
forgetting jamie mccabe
and mcadams rachel
uh pretty good movie what's his name
harrison ford
no patrick wilson yeah uh what else is
he in
he's the one in the commercials what the
guy that
she keeps getting rejected by that's
like the studio
gold bloom oh not as good as jeff
goldberg
oh yeah what was that death glow blue
is it eat ace of cakes yes by the way so
you know that you can't a cake save me
stuff goldblum yes
and you know his real name is jeff
really so i got confused one time
jeff goldblum jeff goldblum yeah yes
very confusing
okay claudia just has a chapter where
she describes stans and fans
growing up who did each of the ashrae
sisters
stan in sync and bachelor boys who was
who
uh jackie was backstreet boys
olivia was in sync and uh jackie and
margo really didn't care about either of
them they were just using you for your
room
claudia and claudia who
i don't spoil too much ben okay who does
claudius stand in her young adult
and not adult young life joe jonas and
margo
it was a brief sentence brief mention i
think i didn't even know i don't even
remember writing that
but i know margot stan growing up i'll
give you growing up
give me a question yes oh yeah i
remember there was that one
yes who does claudia have a poster of
in her college dorm room
you should know yeah i have been there
joe jonas no acceptable answers would
have been taylor swift or one direction
yes okay last question for the win
where are claudia's favorite muffins
from
the corner store outside of nyu yes
called space market iconic muffins so
good double chocolate chip head over
university and eighth street so good you
did great
you losers
yes we're so happy thank you i knew you
read it i was there
yeah i was there but some people just
didn't i was there some people just
didn't believe you pops
no it's because you've been spreading
false libels
you've that's a new game
um everyone please check out my book
girls no job.com
book and it's now available nationwide
six
six six six six six six i'm not
seriously anywhere you get
by the way totally are they a little uh
anti-semitic jesus
what are you missing
yeah but apparently they're named after
mount carmel which is in israel and i
think it's like a jewish only
car company so they're allowed jokes so
it's like you joke yeah but it's just a
bad joke i really don't want to go back
i'm sorry anti-semitic carmel thing like
we did all literally an entire episode
on it
my book is available anywhere you can
get books audiobooks ebooks hardcover
books
everywhere shop local shop amazon shop
bards and nobles shop indie
thank you so much for the never-ending
support on this book i hope you're all
enjoying it
and that you're just cuddle up cuddled
up at home with
your doctor for chemin reading this book
and it's supposed to be a snow day here
so it's a
beautiful day to read a book i mean it's
always a good day to read my book but
yes you're right
yes guys that's all she wrote that's all
she wrote
literally all that she wrote in the book
just 240 pages
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found
so spotify itunes stitcher public radio
i heart radio cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
we hope you have an amazing day happy
pub day to me
bye bye
you